Ça fait un bout de temps qu'il
dit ça déjà, Docteur Karl Weiss,
e. Docteur Weiss,
bonsoir.
- Oui, bonsoir Patonsoir Patons.
- Alors, vous en parlez depuis
des mois, vous, de cette...
de la pandémie quiz
beaucoup : "Ce n'est pas du jour
au lendemain que ça devient
endémique, mais c'est
un processus." Voici que l'OMS
dit ce que vous êde temps. de Çe
quoi pour nous, Docteur Karl
Weiss? Qu'est-ce que ça change?
Dr KARL WEISS, spéc. en maladies
infectieuses, Hôpital gén. juif
il faut comprendre que
la COVID-19 va rester danster ds
notre environnement. Elle ne
disparaîtra pas. Donc, la fin
dire la fin de la COVID.
Donc, on va vivre encore
des temps un peu sous-tension,
lorsqu'on aura peut-être
dans certaines places sur
la planète, il y aura
potentiellement des problèmes.
ça veut dire que revenir
à une étape de couvre-feu,
de fermeture de la société,
de diminution de l'activité
économique, c'est très fort
probablement,
plus dans nos tableaux. La
fermeture des écoles, le
travail, en télétravail pouretc.
qui à grande échelle
n'arriveront plus. Pourquoi? On
voit que globalement, pour
quand ils font la COVID ils sont
peu malades.
Bien sûr il faut regarder ça à
toujours des exceptions,
toujours des groupes à ris
mais pour l'ensemble de la
population aujourd'hui
certain point domptée.
On a aussi beaucou à
part les vaccins et les
traitements pour pouvoir faire
ble et qui ne fait pas
écrouler notre système de santé.
êtes parmi les outils que
nous avons, il y a les vaccins.
Est-ce que les vaccins sont la
principale cause du fait qu'il
n'y a plus beaucoup de gens très
malades?
- Tout à fait. La grande
vécu entre la première la
deuxième vague c'est la. On. Onn
sait qu'aujourd'hui le vaccin ne
protège pas contre les
infections, mais que lalle
est bien protégée par ses
vaccins et lorsqu'elle attrape
la COVID de développer uneomme e
faisait dans le passé.
C'est très évident aujourd'hui.
On voit des gens qui il y a deua
COVID on les a vus dans des
Aujourd'hui on voit des gensâgét
vaccinée qui lorsqu'ils font la
malades. Il y a un changement
important, je vous dirai de la
pathogénie cité de la maladie en
pas auparavant et qui est dure
très grosse partie au vaccin.
Surtout pour la po
risque. C'est ça qu'il faut
souligner.
- D'ailleurs, j'ou
parenthèse. Vous vous êtes
depuis un certain temps :
ceux qui doivent aller chercher
sont les personnes arrêtées.
Quelqu'un qui est anté,
vous vous dîtes que vous pouvez
attendre.
avec raison au début de la
pandémie recette  recette  recet
le monde. Pour que vous ayez
18 ans et que vous soyez en
amples CHSLD tout le monde avait
le même format. Ce que l'on ne
façon évidente.hui avec l'appret
comprendre que quelqu'un ens de
risque et qui est relativement
jeune, qui a eu la COVID qui a
eu trois doses de vaccin,
et qui a eu la COVID depuis le
mois de décembre 2021 et bien si
ces gensAvec l'arrAvec l'arrAvee
nouveaux vaccins qu'on appelle
des vaccins bivalents,
une forme de. Zéro de ses
tentielle d'encore
meilleure sous vaccins on va
dire, sans vouloir entrer dans
des données techniques quimajort
d'aller chercher u
supplémentaire de rappel
aujourd'hui aura relativement
risque de sévérité de la
maladie.
d'aller chercher une dosentairel
aujourd'hui aura relativement
peu d'impact en te
maladie.- Vous dîtes : si vous y
aller allez-y, mais ce qui doit
vraiment y aller cgé ou à risqu,
et avec des maladie sous-
jacente. Les indicateurs sur la
planète baissent partout, mêmeùe
fait?
ça n'a pas été tant vacciné. Il
faut faire attention aux
aujourd'hui comment est au début
de la pandémie. On le voit bien
au Québec, lorsqu'on testait aut
une image beaucoup plus claire
de ce qui s'est passé.
Aujourd'hui conteste que deset c
des techniques TCR et on lai
les gens s'auto testait. Les
groupes ne sont pluse l'on voite
qu'il y a une diminution
importante à peu près partout
sur la planète, nts je voudrais,
c'est le fait qu'o
beaucoup la population.
On ne peut pas comparer tous les
pays les uns aux autres. Des
gens ont une population jeune et
plus âgée. Par exemple de
comparer certains pays comme
l'Italie ou la moyenne d'âge ess
totalement quelque chose qu'peue
pour extrapoler les résultats.
Est-ce qu'on peut dire c'est
qu'avec un monde qui est
beaucoup plus ouvert, imaginez-
vous que quand lesorsorsorsorsos
qu'aujourd'hui on voit qu'il y l
voyage, aux activités normales,
aux actix.
On ne voit pas d'impact majeursr
comme on le voyait au début.plus
qu'on hospitalise aujourd'hui
kit est positif pour la COVI
n'ont pas la COVID comme
diagnostic principal de leur
hospitalisation. S
arrivent à l'hôpital pour une
cause qui est autre. Il ne faut
pas minimiser la C
probablement encore des choses à
rder
le problème de façon différente.
Entre autres au niveau dest
par exemple garder des
travailleurs de la santé
triplement vaccinées qui son
très peu malades kits est
positifs et qu'on garde chez eux
pendant six jours, alors que ces
réseau de la santé et
qu'aujourd'hui avec les mesures
masque ces gens-là pourraient
revenir beaucoup plus rapidement
travail. C'est ce que beaucoup
commence à faire.
- L'Ontario le fait déjà.
Docteur Weiss, vous aviez ra
Les gens qui vous écoutaientvous
vous avez raison.- Il faut être,
dans l'histoire toute lespandéma
preuve c'est que nous sommes
aujourd'hui. On a
les pandémie. On a des outils
technologiques aujourd'hui comme
on a jamais dans l
termes de vaccination de
traitement. La quantité de
nouveau
pipeline est énorme. Il faut
être optimiste. J'ai vu la copie
de cet é
en premier vague. Ça ne veut pas
dire qu'on n'aura pas des
chemin ou des périodesdifficilen
a connu en 2020 n'existera plus
cette belle
phrase, Docteur Ka
merci beaucoup de nous avoir